[Music]
uh so this is pretty bad and here's why
remember we showed uh last week
uh we showed the whole Katie you know
Katie Hobbs who's running against Kerry
Lake in uh Arizona and by the way just
to point out just to point something out
to here real quick
this this this Arizona election is so
important that ABC is in Phoenix right
now to cover it nobody goes to Phoenix
on purpose no of course not it just
always reminds me of that Arrested
Development not just the door handle
that burns it just leaves
um
that's literally what all that [ __ ]
Southwest is like in the day bye so it's
so bad remember we said that she would
not she would not debate her uh it's
gotten so bad that now even ABC is
calling out Katie Hobbs because she
won't debater why have you refused to
debate your opponent she wants to go
head-to-head toe-to-toe with you with a
moderator dozens of interviews and had a
press availability across the state and
we're going to continue to do that and
talk directly to the voters don't you
think perhaps some of your opponents say
it makes you look weak you also refuse
to debate your primary opponent as well
well so they're not backing down like
this is this is one of those where I
thought they were going to back down but
this is a minute of them grilling her
that was a difference but you want to
know why because a lot of people are
like oh my God even the mainstream
medium
the mainstream media are terrified
are terrified
that that Kerry Lake may she looks like
she's going to win this unless they
[ __ ] cheat honestly I think he's
going to win this
so they're now mad at her for going like
do something do something because we're
gonna [ __ ] lose here bro I do like
that she's like but we're you know I've
I've made myself available to the media
and we're talking directly to voters so
basically like you're going to every
scenario where there's no pushback
whatsoever what's funny you said that
because wait till you see what homie
says debate your primary opponent as
well sorry but she's the hot one that I
had the Epstein story right yeah yeah
that's her yeah she's hot yeah she's
afraid as well can I say something honey
I know you're trying to go for the more
mature look but if you were to dye your
hair you would like DH by like 15 years
by the way ever since this [ __ ]
called her Lisa Loeb I can't unsee it at
least a love over here different story
and I won that uh by a wide margin so it
was not an issue but
um but uh yeah watch it watch it the
debate about debates is over I'm running
my campaign the way I'm running my
campaign I'm going to continue to make
the case directly to voters the case you
make to them and not to belabor that
point is they do they are tough times
for a lot of folks we talk about the
economy inflation and I know there's a
rising cost of living here people are
putting somebody in that office that
they want to stand up for them and fight
for them at worst it could come off as
you're scared to step on that stage and
at best you're not willing to confront
we're in a new era where Sometimes some
politicians are seen as bullies and
we've been taught since we were little
kids you got to stand up to a bully you
won't you understand how that might come
across how do you make a case we want to
send you to fight for us so you're going
to try to bully her let me just be clear
here now I want I really want to see
what's going you want to bully her to be
more and they won't say the word but the
whole reason this started is you want
her to be more trump-like because that's
what they want say all we look and we
criticize Trump and we'll probably hit
him in hm anywhere yeah okay I'll do it
right here in front of the helicopter
say what you want about Trump you have
to give him credit with this he talked
to every new station he didn't give a
[ __ ] frankly he stuck around and argued
for too long some days like there were
some of his handlers were like okay
enough man you've been out here arguing
yeah hey you know one more thing go
ahead I'll give you a third question
[ __ ] come on bring It
and that's the point
now here's the truth
politicians to
any woman who has that kind of vocal fry
is the worst
[ __ ] Governor Jules David over here
[Laughter]
Jesus Christ
there's another show coming to you from
Phoenix and it's all important
Battleground State Phoenix what voters
are thinking as they get ready man this
chick holds up oh yeah it's been around
a long time she's still hot and the
Urgent issues driving many Americans to
the point I'd Spike her story
catch my drift well here's ABC's with
Johnson
she looks like you could see her [ __ ]
eyes in the dark bro that's a reptile
[Laughter]
so she's like a cat like when you look
at him down a dark hallway and you just
see two glowing eyes looking at you
[ __ ] man when it comes to voters in the
Battleground State of Arizona also very
Progressive to say she's the one you
can't see at night it's not as simple as
red or blue this show is super
Progressive lately and I'm here for it
that is this is a new this is a
no it's a new immersion that's not true
that's not true that guy smiles
sometimes
it's like the Cheshire Cat
as soon as Royce was like wow how
Progressive I'm like man negro teeth
joke okay perfect there we go
yep
I bought a Democrat for 12 years oh I
built a Democrat for it what is this guy
this guy's [ __ ]
[ __ ] sent none of it matches up the
access the too tight sleeveless shirt
with no guns and the board shorts and
the accent like the [ __ ] the European
guy from Family Guy yeah I will have one
liter of beer Iowa brought this woman
back and I was going to make sex on her
I was totally going to Bone her but I
did not bone her I would like one liter
of petrol please
Democrat for 12 years in the last
eight eight years I've been voting
Republicans did you just get done eating
a jar of peanut butter yes it's
Phoenix's yearly peanut butter Fest you
want cultured swine
hang on I want to hear what David Hogg's
older brother has to say yo this is
[ __ ] terrible yeah it's true
David Hog's Older Brother David warthog
let's see what mayor kirketti has to say
say you're a republican probably the
n-word
do you plan to vote for the Republican
candidate you know anybody who's willing
to talk to local news at this point this
is national news anyone willing to talk
to any TV news but it's ABC so it
doesn't count they're always the biggest
fattest losers right like any like
remember when you're like back in the
day there was a big deal it was all the
local news and like nowadays it's like
anybody with a life like if you were
walking through the mall excuse me ABC
News you'd be like [ __ ] off dude I don't
have time to talk to you for free
well he got to interview Michael even
more so leave it alone
top of mind for many voters here the
economy and inflation it's getting a lot
harder to find like a place or like a
stable place to stay well that's because
I figured it that you know why it's hard
to find a stable place because you're
still sleeping on people's couches
I was about to say [ __ ] the reason he
thinks he's independent is because he
doesn't know the difference between that
and dependent and the gasket and then
they can ask him they can ask him like
who are you voting for oh I can't I have
a felony
yeah
yeah felony districts waste their time
for a half hour and as a common felon I
don't know what you're talking about oh
wait no no even even funnier oh no I
live in Nevada
it's getting really hard to find a place
because I haven't had a job in like five
years you know and I spend all my money
on various fruit shirts
you should see my mango one it's pretty
cool that's what they call people that's
why they call people to judge shirts
prices gas prices and more shirts it's a
fruit shirt yeah we're all going up uh
substantially Phoenix now ranking among
the worst inflation rates in the country
and just also the worst place all around
and no offense I know we have fans from
Phoenix but why to be fair it's because
you also had like the most stable and
like cheap economy for the longest
that's a good point so now you're
getting pulled into the [ __ ] into the
fridge catching up to do anyways now
you're just getting launched into the
[ __ ] with the rest of us
congratulations it's terrible
do you imagine living in Phoenix
I don't know man but what I'm about to
see Republican absolutely 100 you think
so
Trumper
probably pulled up in an F-250 with a
trump flag yes please surprise us okay
if she surprises us Marsh May marry her
so let's find out like look I'm [ __ ]
frankly I'm tired of these baby killing
[ __ ] K words hey let's talk about why
Kanye was right about what yeah why are
they trying to silence a black
billionaire trying to silence like oh
that would be hilarious
yo I downloaded that podcast on my phone
you can take it off the internet but
it's in my heart now I got it on [ __ ]
hard drive so I got thumb drives with
that podcast I throw them out of my car
every year that's unacceptable the board
is security I don't call this
immigration I call it an invasion again
this guy is so I cannot I don't know
what he's like somebody hit the
randomizer dude
so where are you from originally
Colorado
well you're just [ __ ] okay cool cool
cool I got hit in my head by farm
equipment
long time ago
that's why I vote Democrats
I believe everything everything and
everyone should have a little bit of a
pathway to have an acceptance you're an
idiot okay thank you for clarifying it
see I didn't know for a I didn't know
for sure if you were a [ __ ] idiot or
not and then you opened your mouth and
you just a bunch of dribble for it out
listen if you can't dress a lead singer
of pod in a banana shirt who can you
trust it's like I believe that all
people
pld with pld with Rome p-o-d with
[Laughter]
that everyone has a right to be like you
know and have acceptance right it's like
everybody's fine everyone needs to be
like totally chill bro why aren't people
being totally chill all the time because
I can't find baby formula my baby died
he's like the doctor in Idiocracy
what do you expect from a guy who's
favorite [ __ ] band is Hoobastank
no skillet by the way this is what he
looks like actually 99 of the time
I deserve get a little [ __ ] RuPaul's
slag race over here
that's very funny here this is about to
say your body women deserve better can
we get one to talk about it then because
that would be super great can you find
one sir because I would really
appreciate it okay thank you look at
Neanderthal looking [ __ ] [ __ ] my
Manute Bol over here and a wig is gonna
goddamn tell me what to do
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] off how about
that
Why You Gotta Kill
me by the way I love this women deserve
better why yeah how about this no you
don't no you don't hang on guys Ernie
Hudson's wearing a wig and he has an
opinion
I hope it's about busting and hopefully
it's ghosts
as I call it a lot of paperwork that a
police officer doesn't want to do right
by the way glory to the newborn king
what if he had been aborted yeah
what what
converging Mary that young [ __ ] that
young woman with her new husband decided
to get an abortion because she could she
decided no you know I gotta Focus I'm
young I got my whole life ahead of me
and I got to get my career in order what
happened then huh Jesus [ __ ] there's
nothing more ironic than people that
have like a [ __ ] job of Jesus sign in
their kitchen and they're like we need
more abortions they're like well you
know the more abortions you have the
more you're statistically probably gonna
kill Jesus you happy with yourself
you killed Jesus now man
good job
hey merch I have a question is Phoenix
where Chipotle was born
it feels it feels like it right it's
such a generic [ __ ] it is
you're right it would be no it was
probably even worse it was probably
found it in Tempe yes okay hold on where
was the first Chipotle okay let's see
Denver
that's that that tracks but you know
what you think so much okay because
Denver's like the gateway to all those
Southwest places so that's a good point
and it is like that that makes it even
more like shitty generic like oh yeah
we're getting Denver style Southwest
food
you know what Chipotle I call it when
I'm eating I go I hate this but it's the
best
I love how this guy talks to these
people like the retards that they are it
just makes me so happy like usually I
hate when the media treats like the
commoners like [ __ ] lessons but these
people really are [ __ ] losers in
Phoenix again the way he's talking to
him some Republicans don't say the same
thing listen let me explain something to
you I really sorry
let me I I really love that we have
Phoenix fans because it shows that we do
reach out to the special needs Community
I was just happy to find out they had
internet out there it's crazy they just
got it out West it's got it no offense I
love your beautiful University hey how's
the University of Phoenix football team
[Music]
all right your biggest school is an
online one
sorry I like Arizona State University
number one for herpes that's right hey
barely beating out UT they're going to
change the name from the Sun Devils to
the ASU crotch Devils
FSU at least we're not ASU that's what
they always say exactly
a lot of women in particular but that's
true I've heard they're all branded with
a
lizard tattoo no that was Nexium yeah
you're thinking
Nexium a lot of girls from Smallville
yeah no that was a different
functionally there's not really a lot of
difference so you know what you know
when they when little little Hispanic
babies are born I could tell you
firsthand that they pierced their ears
immediately
um when you're a baby born in Phoenix
they do give you an iguana tattoo right
away immediately right away [ __ ] stamps
that's how they know you're fixed that's
how they know yeah so that when they
release you back out into the wild if
another Trapper picks you have to go oh
no he's fixed
laughs
and they put a tracker in the back of
your neck
I'm kidding I've never been to Phoenix
thank God that's what I did
I've never been so low in my life that
I've had to go to Phoenix see I've
actually been to Phoenix before Oh big
Charles Barkley fan no it's called a
layover oh that's right
I've had one beer in Phoenix because my
flight was delayed
I am a republican but I also believe
that there are situations that women
have in their life that can't be
governed man did you have one ma'am do
you do you have a setting above four
some easy goes you guys need to take a
trip to Sedona that'll change your mind
okay on our way dude this woman sounds
like like you know when you get like a
cheap Bluetooth speaker or like cheap
earbuds and you're like trying to turn
them up and you're like this is as loud
as he's getting huh when they give you
the I always I always call those those
tier of headphones airplane headphones
yes the freebies they give you because
you're like I'd rather have nothing
because I can't hear first off my ears
are clogged because we're in the air and
these things make no sound I just feel
like I'm like click click click click
click and I'm like this lady is not
getting any louder oh boys there's some
Phoenix people getting mad there's
there's a phoenix Florida where going on
yeah they're in Phoenix I'd be [ __ ]
furious yeah we have a beach you guys
think we have we have no humidity I have
a beach I I have to have it be every
direction except for North we have a
beach yeah we don't have any humidity
yeah you don't have any sources of water
at all
hot [ __ ] hot are you guys live in
that little thing you're literally
you're bragging rights or we have no we
literally have no moisture in the entire
State yeah yay [ __ ] these
[ __ ] living in the village of
The Three Amigos pretending like they're
better than us get out of here
that was who's your mayor still El Guapo
leave me alone
I'll have you know we're like Mars
there's not a trace of any kind of H2O
anywhere in our state boom take that
Florida [ __ ] film the moon landing in
Phoenix it's like Oh no you're right you
got us beat we all we have is Tom Brady
and beaches
and more strip clubs for Kathy hey
that's completely do me a favor let's
compare a phoenix 7 to a Tampa seven and
let's see who wins well we don't have
any humidity yeah we have boats
awesome
um
you know what that's really I mean look
listen Phoenix we have in Florida
[ __ ] plants
[ __ ] grass
and [ __ ]
oh hey what are the rocks in my front
yards and everybody in Phoenix
we have fruit that grows right in the
ground here you [ __ ]
on the ground with your bare feet and
[ __ ] once in a while a dog in the Chacos
but do you have meth yes we also have
meth we cannot pretend we don't have
meth we also have meth
uh somebody said Florida has more Jewish
people fair enough you have a lot of
math here it's mostly made in Arizona
why are we [ __ ] on things so hard
they're doing the nuts because a few
people took exception and I had to
triple their parts of course
you're kidding Phoenix we hate you
um I just want to sit here and drink
sodas and eat [ __ ] cupcakes from
Mindy's Bakery [ __ ] on Arizona for
[ __ ] an hour and then I'll just be
doing this next to you
I'm sure I'm [ __ ] tired I'm old and I
work with [ __ ] children and then I'm
gonna I'm gonna shake my head and agree
to make me look even stupider in front
of you dude the best part is with it
just that that when somebody did the
zoom in and you see him like
what's happening